Marvel Studios has just announced
something that is going to completely
change the MCU Marvel Studios has just
introduced new content to the MCU and no
I'm not talking about a new show or a
new movie although yes they are
introducing a new show but the format of
the content is different it's a new
categorization for Marvel Studios that
they're going to be grouping a lot of
newer Disney Plus shows with and I think
some fans might actually find this
pretty awesome and it's definitely a
strategy for Marvel Studios to kind of
fight the superhero fatigue that some
people may be experiencing right now
with the MCU and it's definitely a way
to enjoy content a little bit more
coming from Marvel Studios what's up
everybody welcome back to the channel
I'm Warren and again I'm still kind of
sick so part of my voice today but I
think Marvel Studios just came out with
an amazing plan they are introducing a
new category to the MCU which they have
called Marvel Spotlight the shows that
will come out for Marvel Spotlight and
Possible movies are still fullon shows
and if they're movies they going to be
full-on movies these aren't specials or
shorts or anything like that they're
still full on projects but they have a
very specific purpose a purpose that I
think a lot of fans are going to find
pretty refreshing and they announced
this with the release of the Echo
trailer yesterday which by the way looks
fantastic and it's the first Marvel
project to get a TV M mature rating I'm
sure Daredevil is going to have the same
especially since it involves Kingpin as
well but Ekko came out first so Ekko is
the first one in the MCU to get a TV
mature rating and Ekko is also the first
project to fall under this category of
Marvel Spotlight there's some key things
that you need to know about this that of
course we'll break down in this video
but if you're new be sure to subscribe
so you don't miss out on any of the
latest MCU news and if you subscribe and
leave a comment you're automatically
entered in our monthly giveaway for a
chance to win a PS5 an Xbox series X
some Marvel Legends items or some DC
items the winner gets to pick one item
and we pick one winner at the end of
each month so I'm sure sure everybody's
biggest question is will these Marvel
Spotlight projects still connect to the
MCU and the answer is yes however these
Marvel Spotlight projects serve a very
specific point and that point is you do
not have to watch pretty much anything
else that Marvel Studios has put out for
the MCU to follow a Marvel Spotlight
project you can go in without knowing
really anything about the MCU or any
other project that has existed in the
MCU this is what Marvel Studios said
about it this is coming straight from
marvel.com when they released Ekko they
stated Ekko will be the first series
under the Marvel Spotlight banner and
head of streaming Brad wibom said of the
decision to launch a new Banner with
Echo Marvel Spotlight gives us a
platform to bring more grounded
character driven stories to the screen
and in the case of Ekko focusing on
street level Stakes over larger MCU
continuity just like the comics fans
didn't need need to read Avengers or
Fantastic 4 to enjoy a ghost riter
Spotlight comic our audience doesn't
need to have seen other Marvel series to
understand what's happening in Maya's
story so right away let me know what you
think about this I think it's a pretty
good plan because there are people out
there who want to watch some Marvel
projects but they say well I haven't
seen these other ones or I haven't seen
this movie to really know what's going
on you hear it right now for Captain
Marvel you hear people say well I don't
know who Miss Marvel is I don't know who
monar Rambo is because they didn't watch
W division or they didn't watch Miss
Marvel so now they're a little apperent
to go see the Marvels because they don't
know who these characters are they don't
know what the stories were before this
leading up we also heard this a little
bit before and after Multiverse of
Madness with people not having seen
Wanda Vision they went into Doctor
Strange wondering all of a sudden why
Wanda was a villain for those who didn't
watch the show that kind of came out of
nowhere to them they didn't know about
the darkhold they didn't know about
Wanda holding Westview hostage now for
the Diehard MCU fans like myself and
probably you since you're watching this
video we typically watch everything this
isn't that big of a deal to us but for
the more casual audience this is
actually a pretty good strategy by
Marvel Studios and I think it's going to
really help with the superhero fatigue
that some people do experience and I
think this is just part of one change
that Marvel Studios is really going to
make and they have already introduced
the new intro for Marvel Studios
spotlights projects which you can see
right now
[Music]
this is clearly part of Marvel studios's
plan moving forward not only for just a
good strategy for the company but I do
believe it's still part of the MCU
strategy and still part of Kevin fagg's
plan we'll talk about that in just a bit
but first big thank you to fume for
sponsoring this video fume is a game
changer for a lot of people in turning
bad habits into good habits a lot of
people struggle with these bad habits
but fume looks at these in a different
way not everything in the habit is wrong
so instead of a drastic uncomfortable
change why not just remove the bad from
your habit and that's exactly what fume
does they're Innovative and they're
award-winning and they're a flavored air
device that's all it is it's flavored
air so it has none of the bad things in
the bad Habit in it instead of vapor it
uses flavored Air instead of electronics
fume is completely natural and instead
of harmful chemicals fume uses delicious
flavors I had actually heard really
great things about fume from my friends
who were struggling with some bad habits
they actually raved about it and how it
helped them which is why I agreed to
partner with them and they sent me some
samples and they honestly are super
refreshing and taste very flavorful and
good and it comes in beautiful real wood
and it's honestly really fun to just sit
there and kind of fidget with if you're
someone who likes to fidget like I do
and I know stopping is something we all
put off because it's hard but with fume
it's easy and they have served over
150,000 customers and have thousands of
success stories and that could be you if
you pick up a journey pack today head
over to
try.com and use code Cosmic to save 10%
off when you get the journey pack today
that's trf m.com and use code Cosmic to
save an additional 10% off your order
today Marvel Spotlight will also take
care of a problem that a lot of fans
have been complaining about recently and
that is a lack of connectivity to the
larger MCU and by simply labeling a
project putting it under the category of
a Marvel Spotlight that'll tell you
right away hey this isn't really going
to connect to that much overall it's
going to be a oneoff standalone project
that you can enjoy on its own you don't
have to see anything else to know what's
going on and you can just enjoy it but
at the same time these projects are
still a part of the MCU don't get that
confused they still exist inside the
Marvel Cinematic Universe and Ekko is a
perfect example of that they chose a
good project to kick off Marvel
Spotlight with because Ekko was a good
character in the Hawkeye series although
she wasn't the main character same with
Kingpin he was only introduced in the
latter episodes however of course it
does connect to Hawkeye and Hawkeye
connects to The Avengers etc etc and of
course we know that moving forward
Daredevil is going to be in the Echo
series and Kingpin who is the villain of
the echo series is also going to be the
villain of the Daredevil Series so you
can see this all still connects very
heavily to the MCU however the story the
story of the entire series and of Ekko
is very secluded in the fact that you
don't have to have watched those shows
or the movies to know what's going on in
the show you can sit back relax and just
enjoy a one off story but at the same
time the character could show up in the
future just in a way that's like hey
here's Ekko you don't have to know the
story that happened in the Ekko series
but you know that ekko's a character and
then she'll come in to be a part of a
team or sometimes maybe not we don't
know if Ekko is going to go on to fight
with Daredevil in the Daredevil series
or be a part of the street level
Avengers team we don't know that she
could get her series and be done and I
think that's kind of the point of Marvel
Spotlight is that they're going to do
oneoff show sometimes where it's just
hey we're introducing this character
they don't necessarily go on to be a
part of a bigger team but they are a
comic book character that a lot of
people like and they're going to get
their own show and it's going to be
secluded and you're going to be able to
watch it casually while at the same time
having this character debut in the MCU
does open up any character that's under
Marvel Spotlight to appear later on in a
way that makes it to where you don't
actually have to know their backstory
too much which again I think is a really
good idea I think it's a great idea for
Marvel to do this because I think it's
going to exhaust people a little bit
less in fact I think it's going to be
refreshing for some people no pressure
of having to watch it anything before no
pressure of guessing how it connects to
the overall MCU or what comes after the
show but simply just watching a show for
what it is enjoying a story and then
after you're done right now with Loki
season 2 although I am absolutely in
love with it and I love theorizing
what's coming next A lot of people are
saying well we only have one episode
what happens next what happens in King
Dynasty Deadpool 3 secret Wars and while
myself and a lot of people do love
wondering what comes next some people
just want closure and a conclusion and
that's exactly what these Marvel
Spotlight projects are basically going
to give us so overall it's a really
great idea for Marvel Studios but go
ahead and let us know what you think
about this in the comments down below do
you like it do you not like it are you
excited do you not care at all leave
your thoughts in the comments don't
forget to like the video and subscribe
so you don't miss out on any of the
latest news you can follow us on
Instagram and Twitter as well and as
always thank you all so much for
watching woof
woof